et la teinte enrico comment ça va la 4g
des pertes de mémoire des tissus
d'alzheimer je sais pas qui c'est on a
fait un alzheimer est justement l rico
je vais vous dire les les titres de
chansons et puis vous allez me dire si
vous avez chanté ou pas hein on va voir
attention parce qu'on a beaucoup quant à
marc vous avez écrit beaucoup de
chansons 1
allons-y adieu mon pays oui salut ma
couille
oui avant deux femmes à dublin oui de
[ __ ] à pigalle oui dix mois ce qui va
pas oui enfants de tous pays
ouais ce clip de toutes les couleurs je
n'ai jamais vu j'irai jusqu'au en
auvergne oui j'irai jusqu'à roubaix mais
je vois partir et tout de suite
ouais ça me rappelle quelque chose c'est
l'accordéon dans les rues de paris
oui la femme de mon ami oui la femme de
mon ami est devenue la mienne a informé
le pour toi mabrouk
malheur à celui qui blesse un enfant oui
malheur à celui qui touche à ma mercedes
olala le monde jean de l'amour même bien
sûr le clochard du sexe ou moi la porte
oui où je vois la porte je défends ce
connard alors oui un berger est tombé
oui un berger est tombé veut dire que ça
glisse paris tu ne représentes par
itunes a pris dans tes bras
oui paris paris je t'encule
m comme ainsi à 32 6 1 en 1h fournissait
de la vie populaire sans nous
rio
le pensions